[Music]
[Applause]
is that a shotgun for like 60 bucks
serious can you be nice for one second
hey how's it going my name is Pippa
I'm markiplier on Tommy's good and I'm
also markiplier we're not here this bad
just to [ __ ] that constantly we're gonna
play this game loser gets shocked and
has to eat a song a biscuit race the
stakes of this one every time I play
this I've lost good these days in the
you tell me one we was over by a private
okay just grab it and close your eyes I
have no down the button yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
that cameras so on the one don't worry
an hour into getting to New York I like
I like got a haircut like I'm feeling my
look I'm just figured I'm like do not
the makeup on my open wound you gonna
burn also we discovered that is a [ __ ]
button elimination we're switching I I
just want to go to neck - balls -
butthole - teeth
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh [ __ ] again yeah I am actually
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh that's a good shot oh you have to
press that book press the button wait if
I tease my do it now for a while
[Music]
Oh